you mentioned jane goodall you've worked
with her
what was it like working with her what
have you learned from her
well she's a wonderfully independent
um courageous person you know who she
famously began her studies
not as a qualified person
in terms of
education
but
qualified only by enthusiasm and
a considerable experience even in her
early 20s with nature
so she's courageous in the sense of
being able to you know take on our
challenges
the thing that is very impressive about
her is
uh her
total fidelity to the observations
uh very unwilling to extend
uh beyond the observations uh we know
waiting until they mount up and you've
really got a confident picture
um and
um
tremendous attention to
individuals
so
you know that was an interesting problem
from her point of view because
when she got to know the chimpanzees
of of gambi this particular community of
casa kayla about 60 individuals
so gombi was in tanzania on
lake tanganyika she was there initially
with her mother and then alone for
uh two or three years of really intense
observation
and then slowly joined by other people
what
what she discovered
was that there were obvious differences
in
individual personality and the
difficulty about that was that
when she reported this to
uh
the larger scientific world initially
her advisors at at cambridge
uh
they said well you know we don't know
how to handle that because uh you've got
to treat all these animals as the same
basically because
um
there is no
research tradition of thinking about uh
personalities well now
whatever it is 60 years later
i the study of personalities is uh is a
very rich part of the study of animal
behavior
um at any rate the important point in
terms of you know what was she like is
that she stuck to her guns and she
absolutely insisted that you know we
have to
show
describe in great detail the differences
in personality among these individuals
and then you can leave it to the
evolutionary biologist to think about
what it means
you